though I just think at the end of the
day 90 of abortions nowadays are
elective and they're women making bad
decisions can I I just think that's it
well I think it's women honestly because
we went around and everybody said the
reasons why they got an abortion and are
their friends got an abortion and the
majority was wrong partner a wrong time
so it kind of sounds like a responsible
can I just say like toxic Partners
they're not always obvious in the
beginning so you might think someone is
great you have a child like later down
the line and then they're toxic like if
you see these warning signs surely you
know get out sooner but but it does
sometimes and I would have a lot of
sympathy if those women
um asked their parents for their advice
because half the time these women they
won't ask their parents advice and when
their parents give them advice and say
no that's a bad guy they don't listen
anymore
um not everyone you know everyone can
get advice from their parents exactly
I'm not saying every single person but I
am saying I see that often and in the
majority of times in toxic relationships
I just see women not listening but you
also have to consider especially their
friends will say something too they'll
be like yeah I mean I'm sure all of you
have said something to a friend that
that boyfriend is toxic or crazy and the
women don't listen 100 but you just have
to think about the woman as well and
there's Sometimes women are in
vulnerable situations people deal with
mental health they maybe can't feel like
they can't leave there's a lot of
different sex no I know but to me this
is just excuses when at the end of the
day it's you making a choice and I think
you're responsible for the choices you
make you know do you know sorry to cut
you you know what not every woman is
strong there's a lot of weak women out
here okay and they're weak for all
different type of reasons yeah and
they're not able to
see a good man yeah a lot of these women
might have had a really bad relationship
and then instead of taking the necessary
time to heal they get into another
relationship and what happens is they
see this person this new guy as
something amazing because he's probably
better than the last one who was abusive
yeah but the next guy still isn't Prince
Charming Sid isn't going to be there
still might be there for two three years
yeah but but but it takes it takes a bit
my thing is like take responsibility for
your choices I hear you but you you have
to understand that some people are not
very intelligent some people don't are
not awakened to certain things they just
make terrible decisions
like what I mean aren't they also
responsible for I mean takes two to
Tangles yeah exactly it's like
is the woman is the woman supposed to
make sure that the male wears them
they also have to take to come yes I do
think you should make sure that the
person you're sleeping with is wearing
and you're right we could say we're
condom equally responsible fine fine
we'll agree with that but you know with
the women we have plan B we have
abortion
um we also have um we also have um what
do you call it what 40 forms of birth
control we have all these different we
can get the thing in your arm you can
get an IUD you can take the pill
I just I love women can't get any
contraceptive though it's free I'm sorry
I don't know if there's things
but if we look at the numbers 53 percent
of women aren't wearing a condom with a
new partner can I have to me that just
screams irresponsible
contraceptions what are they using other
contraception I I don't know
you know what else can I just say I
think
um I think you're right about I think I
think that the abortion
being pushed the way it is has
encouraged
people being promiscuous I think that
there is a lot of stupid girls and guys
out there that are sleeping around that
uh like oh it's my whole face like and
like hot girls summer and all these it's
it's promoting
bad
nasty yeah it's basically like
promiscuous behavior and one out of
three women have had an abortion like
it's a form of birth control at this
point well the younger is getting
younger and younger and younger yeah and
I think that there is so many girls that
I'd say that the girls that are now
probably 10 to 15 in like 10 years time
they're gonna have had like 10 plus
abortions that one girls that are for
abortion but there is a lot of girls
that I have heard you know in school
that I've spoken to from high school
that I've already had like two three
abortions and they're in high school
yeah and and they're not it's it's
nothing to them it's like oops like just
get another one oh it's happened again
pro-choice people can we have an
abortion cap like after three now you
know you need to keep this child this is
just irresponsible do you know what um
abortion medication is
do you know what it does which what do
you mean well abortion medication it
induces right so it's not this special
pill that goes and just kills the fetus
it causes the body of the mother to
eject it right so it's not killing it
it's making the area in which it's
growing in a hospitable
so which does what
well it rejects it it causes a
miscarriage right so that does what
well then the argument is it was it
alive because we have to we have to
Define what being alive is and whether
so I see a pregnancy as a potential life
not as a life until something sitting in
front of me it's not a life that doesn't
mean that I don't can make
considerations for how we perceive women
who are pregnant especially later on in
pregnancy those two things are not
particularly related and my opinions are
more on a societal basis and not from
any argument from Consciousness or
really that much bodily autonomy for
example if we say oh well it will
definitely survive at six months um
although that already is the cut off
in which case I said some some children
survived at like five and a half months
before well then I I have no issue with
potential C-sections or whatever
happening at any point in time but the
reality is like they're gonna live so
there's no point speculating about eight
or nine month abortions because that
wouldn't make any sense sorry they'll
cut you what did you say your name was
again sorry uh Kelly Kelly
um on Google it says that they're on
Google
Google says
no I'm just saying legally you can't get
a birth certificate for a death of a
child unless it's
um like actually being born so if you
have like a still bath or you have like
um like say you want to carry through
with your pregnancy and you get to like
five six months you're excited about
your pregnancy you've told everyone
about your pregnancy you're looking
forward to your child coming your child
dies you haven't given birth to your
child you're really telling me I can't
get a death certificate for my child and
to me that's my child you know I mean I
want to mourn like and stuff like that
so if
um with um pro-life
um people that are with pro-life it's
like it's a when you said um sorry when
you said a child like is not really like
a person until they're born
so what about the moms that think that
that child is a person they're growing
with a baby inside of their belly they
want to like have something to stop
anyone for a morning but laughs
regardless but you don't have a death
certificate
for your child so how do you you can't
have a funeral you can't really have a
funeral you can still have a funeral I
know but it's not really like like
something for yourself like say you you
want to have something to keep that to
say I had this baby that this existed
this happened you know I mean you can't
really have that so it's like saying oh
before my child's world my child's not a
child but if my child's not a child then
how can people really argue and say that
abortion is wrong if the child's not a
child then you've made you've made a
really good point because you've said
about
um you can't get a birth certificate
until you're born so I understand my
death certificate if the child dies and
you haven't given birth to that child
yet during your pregnancy yeah yeah yeah
that makes sense is that that makes
sense to me in my mind logically that
makes perfect sense why would you get a
death certificate if you haven't
received a birth certificate well but
what is
the child has an been born yet then
technically that's if the child hasn't
been born yet then you're saying that's
not in life some people saying that's
not alive it has not been born yet so if
someone has it's a living organism yes
depending on how far along it is but it
has not been born don't get interested
I'm pro-choice don't get interested I'm
poor choice but I'm saying what I'm
saying is for people that are pro-life
if you have an abortion before the child
is born that is wrong right for you to
have an abortion before you've given
birth to a child so there's some of the
some of the same people that are also
pro-life will not they'll they're with
like not how can you not have a death
certificate it's not a child right you
get what I'm trying to say if it's not
alive if it's not I don't know if I'm
not explaining what I'm trying to say
probably to get what I'm trying to say I
sort of do sort of that so you're saying
why why don't they have a death
certificate yes if the child is in if if
in your eyes the child is alive is
considered a child before the child's
being born then that child when it dies
before being born should be should be
allowed a death certificate to say that
this child was something this child
existed right you know what I mean but
it's not it's illegal but in certain
countries it's illegal to have an
abortion but it's also illegal to have a
death certificate before 24 weeks it
doesn't make sense it's it's all
hypocritical all of it the life the
choice the like you do like we just said
that I don't know if you heard but if a
woman gets killed and she's pregnant she
could have just become pregnant the day
before I think they find out I think the
problems are not hypocritical I think it
makes perfect sense because we would say
it's a double homicide and we as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible